欢迎收看
理财大人秀的
《筹码教学单元》
歌有筹必报
这也是号称
我们教学单元里面
最喜欢开车的
最近非常多的MeToo
但是我们必须说
在这个场合是没有MeToo的
但如果您听了不是很舒服
也只好请您忍耐下去
好
今天我们要教的东西呢
这是一个高速运转的东西
到底高速运转你会开心还是不开心呢
我们最近看股票常常会发现
创高了
然后就会出现警告说
这个周转率非常高
可是大家知道吗
周转率高并不代表就是不好
代表玩的人很多很急很快
那到底要怎么来看这个周转率的好跟坏呢
到底快这件事情是好事还是坏事
快这件事情是好事还是坏事
对
要看快這個夠不夠持久
夠不夠持久
對
可是快跟持久好像不是同一個形容
有的動作很快但是沒有很持久
有的動作很快又很持久
有的動作很快又沒有很持久
那周轉率算哪一種
周轉率喔 周轉率就是翻周率
你可以把它想成翻周率
那周轉率很高的時候
你在盤中看盤的數字跳得很快
跳動很快
跳動很快我們就看他有沒有很持久
哎呦
假如沒有很持久
跳動很快
欸沒有很持久
那可能高點快要到了
是
因為代表想買的人都買了
想賣的人都賣了
等一下就不行了是不是
就不行了
就會垂下來了
我說那個股價
股價就會垂下來了
股價就會垂下去了
對對對
我們可以這樣子來做判斷
好
那到底什麼是股票周轉率
不曉得大家聽完有沒有聽懂
可能滿腦子都想別的
我剛剛講這段話
有沒有對你造成什麼不大舒服的
不會啊
我們講的是股票上的know how
有記得提早講
是知識不是知識
你不要再30年後
突然說有一天我錄影的時候
那一天好像不大舒服
對不愉快
覺得被騷擾了
那我就完蛋了
那你講一下什麼是股票多轉率
是股票周轉率
那股票周轉率呢
是股票在股市中
這個買賣的過程
一段時間我們來衡量一下
一段時間來衡量
那計算股票的成交量
佔股票總數的比例
是
那周轉率呢
你可以把它想像換手率
就像翻桌率一樣
是
那周轉率怎麼算呢
很簡單
股票成交量
除以該股票的流通股數
乘100%
所以就是如果
今天的成交量
剛好等於它的流通股數
就等於今天全數人都換手過一次
都換手過一次
不要以為沒有
還真有這樣的股票
100%不算什麼
你知道我看過幾%的嗎
幾%
500%
每一個人都玩五趟
每一個人玩五趟
一天玩五趟
非常厲害
體力很好
身體也很好
一天玩五趟
後來是翹起來還是垂下去呢
股價
垂下去
用太兇
對 而且打折打滿多的
那個500%以後
股價呢
腰斬 再腰斬 再腰斬 打了一整
身體壞掉了
壞掉了不可以我們來玩啦我們來玩就出事了那我們來聊一下等一下會告訴大家什麼叫健康的周轉率什麼叫不健康的周轉率
因為有的周轉率太不健康了
太大了
周轉率太大了
不大好
做個手術
我們看一下
這個高周轉率的定義
股票周轉率代表著股票的流動率
那高周轉率呢
據我多年的觀察
一天大概是大於20%
就高啊
一天20%很多耶
可是我看最近真的超級多標股
就7%、7、80
100...這公司也才1萬張股票
要2000張拿出來玩
算不算很多耶
算不大穩定了耶
你看台積電的周轉率
它毫時大概都低於5%
都很低啦
有時候可能都不到1%
所以這個周轉率高
這個通常在高檔不是什麼好事情
這一天大於20%
我們就叫高周轉率
或者是一周大於100%
一周大於100%也算很多的
這個我們就可以來幫助你
作為進出場的參考
因為通常要有量才會有價
那有量代表著周轉率也高
所以你可以去找高周轉率的股票來做
保證看盤不會睡著啦
絕對不會睡著
是
作轉率低的看看都會睡著
因為沒有量
作轉率高的喔
盤中震盪很刺激喔
好
那高到作轉率的股票呢
我們來看它的優缺點喔
第一個優點
交易活絡
是
進出容易
唉唷
進出容易是優點嗎
當然是優點啦
進出不容易卡卡就不好啦
喔
好
就卡卡就不好
這也是一種契合的概念
缺点呢
短线高档
我们要小心主力有出货的状况
主力不行了
倒给你了
它趁高落盘
趁着这个混乱之际
把股票倒给你
那这个都会在高周转率的股票上
高周转率的股票
有优点也有缺点
所以要看的是什么呢
在某些时候它是优点嘛
对
对不对
是的
有些時候是優點
那我們先來教各位
怎麼呢 怎麼先查
怎麼查高周轉率
高周轉率股票呢
這個取得較來源很多
各大券商網站其實都有
你在Google打高周轉率其實很多
很容易查到
貴買中金這邊也有
他告訴你說 今天高周轉率股票有哪些
那自己講這個是
6月19號高周轉率股票
可是貴買是不是就只有上櫃公司
他怎麼不順便幫上市弄一下
各管各的
不過坊間有些網站都把你整合了
你就可以一次看
那高週轉率股票
像我今天
今天的銀幫蠻強的
對啊 可能銀幫今天漲停辦
對啊 今天富爺也漲停
所以高週轉率常常也很有量
也常常是強勢股
因為強勢股大家追
大家追喔 所以高周轉率股票
通常都還蠻強的
所以反而看到高周轉率先不要覺得快不行
可以先看一下搞不好股價是走強的
那所以呢我們就要來特別注意一下
高周轉率的一些狀況
那高周轉率取得的資料來源像MoneyDJ也有MoneyDJ他有跟你寫上市周轉率的排行還有上跪周轉率的排行
這邊都寫出來
那我們來看一下
上市周轉率排行
來看6月19號
第一名十全
是
還有華金
華金這昨天的啦
對
華金昨天的周轉率超高
將近五成
昨天華金
這個開高殺到平盤
又拉到漲停
這種周轉率一定很高
反正只要政府大 周轉率就會很高
不過他被關了
還有這幾檔
0067國泰日金
日金周轉率怎麼高
四星科 四星科今天又漲停
今天漲停
所以你看周轉率高的股票
通常還蠻有意思的
都有動
底下是上跪
好
那高周轉率呢
我們就要來看看這個
籌碼的操作新法啦
就剛剛講的有時候是好事
有時候是壞事
第一個呢 股票在低檔
主力買
那這種呢 容易有波段行情
那什麼叫低檔呢
就是它股票已經在那邊混很久
那很多條均線都糾結了
5日 10日 20日 60日
都糾結了
然後呢 突然有一天周轉率非常高
然後爆大量 它可能就是一個波段行情出現
第二個呢 假如股票在高檔
那你要特別看一個東西 主力有沒有賣超
假如主力賣超 你就要小心被出貨
所以股票在高低檔的位置 其實蠻關鍵的 對不對
真的 那個股票高低檔位置呢 真的很關鍵
那高低檔到底要怎麼看
我叫各位看一下
什麼叫高檔什麼叫低檔
好模糊啊
其實你可以看年限
通常我們這個講高低檔的時候
我們都會用年限來判斷
那離年限附近的
它就算低檔
舉例來說我們來看這一天
這一天喔
華星光平常都沒什麼亮
這裡都沒什麼亮
突然這天有亮了
那這天的亮呢算起來
他的周轉率來到了21%
欸 高
剛好過了20%門檻
然後你看一根大黃K
就是一個波段的起漲
所以股票在低檔
各位看到這一根之前
你看這主力在這裡就轉成買超了
那外資呢
這個一買一賣
不過也有連續買的狀況
也有投信買
所以看起來這邊也有分點連續買
所以看起來就是一個
一些主力大戶都進來晚了
都進來晚了 它的周轉率就變高
你看後面的周轉率是更高了
那它的行情就一路的往上走
所以股票在低檔主力買
它就容易有波段行情
因為只要周轉率超過20%
很多人的眼睛都看過來
看過來是不是要吵了
超過20%就是一個門檻
終於是低檔在起漲區的時候超過20%
代表關注的眼光過來囉
這時候就是好事情
接下來我們來看第二檔5258的紅寶
紅寶我們來看在這個位置
開布林這一天
這一天周轉率剛好來到了22%
一開布林
雖然他沒有再很低檔可是他也在這裡混一段時間了都混到軍線糾結了均線糾結完了這個開布林低跟周轉率也變大
他又走了一個小小的波段
所以這種股票跟低檔
你可以看一下均線有沒有糾結
其實很容易看
因為高檔你就知道說
他可能離那個月線很遠
乖離率很大
或者是離季線很遠
通常假如在月線跟季線附近的
我們都可以視為低檔
而且它這個布林通道也變成很窄了
很窄了 對
布林通道很窄了 就是壓縮到極致
突然拉一根之後 又是個破檔
好 這個算是比較偏低檔
左轉率高就導致它會有一個破斷行情
但剛剛有講 也會有出貨行情的
對 又高檔的
我們來看一下這個3128的深銳
那深銳我們看這個位置 這邊
這在高檔的時候 你看這已經漲上來了
乖離月限也多 乖離年限也很多
底下這條是年限
漲傷害的過程中 我們看這裡有主力賣的狀況
主力賣 你看在高檔主力也是在賣
那它的周轉率來到了78%
對啊 太誇張了吧
我們看到這種78%
這是很爪
這個是董事長 總經理 副總
全部都是拿出來賣的嗎
不然怎麼周轉率搞那麼高
就等於市場流通1萬張
它有7800張在交易
對 拿出來吧
不過這千八百張裡面
當然會混雜著一些當充客在裡面
那無論如何
我相信公司派可能有拿一些出來賣
不然哪來那麼多籌賣
對 不然不會那麼多量
所以高檔你看高檔有量
周轉率高主力賣
後面就很容易跌一波
然後後面就跌下來
好這個是被出貨的案例
被出貨
那接下來再看另外一個
這個是也是高檔
有被出貨的案例
那這個之前已經更高喔
不過在這個位置稍微反彈一下
我們來看主力是連續波段賣
對
主力連續波段賣
你看他的周轉率來到20%
然後這個
這個周轉率高的時候主力賣
那這種呢很容易又再創新低
所以你看大盤漲到1萬7000
跟金橋沒他的事
因為它在去年漲過了
因為前面有很高的高點
因為看這張圖可能會覺得不會啊
它也平平的
但是之前高點蠻高的
那跌下來過程中你看
這邊也出亮後面也跌下來
可是我覺得像金橋
如果沒有看到前面有高點
會誤以為它要發動會不會
有時候會有這種情況
所以你要看長一點
好 要看長一點
所以這邊關鍵來了
周轉率它不是錯
它是要看出現在哪裡
高周轉率的股票
假設是出現在低檔
有一點起漲的狀態
代表什麼咧?代表它躺在那很久了
現在大家來關注它了
要弄它了
所以比較容易漲喔
但是如果它已經漲了一大段了
這時候周轉率越衝越高
就要非常留意了誰在賣啊?
哪來那麼多籌碼啊?可能所有的公司派
主力都拿出來賣了
那散戶就要千萬提高警覺了
剛剛講的都是範例喔
那最近有哪些股票
有這樣低檔或高檔周轉率變高的現象呢
就要請你們訂閱我們的榮耀班了
在榮耀班裡面
小哥已經幫大家找出
最近很值得你鎖股觀察的標的喔